a taste of freedom in Spain for seven
weeks people here endured one of the
strictest social restrictions in Europe
now they're allowed to exercise outdoors
most adults can walk or play sports
during set hours in the morning and
evening restaurants remain closed for
now and people using public transport
will have to wear a mask Spain had one
of the worst outbreaks in the world even
though it is over the peak of those
fatalities the Prime Minister announced
that the state of emergency would remain
in place for another two weeks we are
winning the battle against the epidemic
but with a very high cost on lives and
sacrifices the virus is not left the
virus is still out there chasing and we
have to be ready to react and logically
to govern these transitions to that new
normality in France the state of
emergency will remain in place for
longer until the 23rd of July travelers
including French citizens returning home
from abroad will have to South
quarantine for 14 days the next few
weeks and months will be about learning
how to live with the virus that is what
this draft law presented during the
Council of Ministers by the Prime
Minister meeting today is preparing
while some countries are seeing the
light at the end of the lockdown the
streets of Moscow are distinctly empty
this weekend this is the Ground Zero of
the corona virus pandemic in the country
and there are alarming signs that Russia
now has the second-highest spread of
kovat 19 overnight into Saturday a spike
of nearly 10,000 new cases of a disease
was reported the highest daily rise
since the start of the pandemic in the
country mostly in Moscow were the mayor
warned that up till 1 in 50 residents
could be infected affecting even the
prime minister Mihiel me shooting who
announced that he tested positive for
covered 19 two days ago the country has
been in lockdown for five weeks yet the
infections continue to grow
exponentially the worst may yet come
sonica a go al-jazeera